Why don't we go next to, um.
Let's go to Ricky Allen from Iowa, Ricky
Allen from Iowa. You're on the air.
Ricky, you from Iowa, you've got it on mute
and then we'll be able to hear you and talk.
Hey, David, what's up? Hey,
there you are. How are you?
No, I'm actually Ricky from G.E., which is Jimmy.
From Jamaica, OK, I guess it must be some kind of
lower case, J that looks like an eye.
No, is G capital G?
Yes, this is my second time. I was actually the
first Jamaican caller you were. I remember that.
OK, cool. So what I wanted to do is absolutely
I'm starting to get extremely concerned with the.
Political dynamic on the live,
yes, in which because at one point
I do not want to call in a name, but there are
certain people there, certain individuals in our
community trying to live, which I think
are becoming very counterproductive towards
a political ends in which I think their view of
politics in such a an idealistic framework and
not so much of a pragmatic framework on that,
in my opinion. How do you think we can be more
pragmatic and ensure that our ideology over the
form of left is come to fruition? And because
those commentators will lead you more into
a right wing direction and not so much of
obtaining the political goal?
That's very interesting. This is
a critique I've had of some of the left. Now, I'm
curious, Ricky, are you talking about politicians
or media people that you believe are falling
too far towards idealism rather than pragmatism?
Oh, media, media people. Oh, really, because
honestly, at one point, my introduction to
Leftism was basically Kalkarindji. Mm hmm. And
honestly right now I do not listen to a wow
thing is his approach to politics is
extremely silly and counterproductive
because you think he's you're saying he's
too idealistic and not pragmatic enough.
That's exactly what I'm saying. And
Jimmy Stewart, Jimmy Stewart, also these
it did. Do we have you in politics?
I think the lead people to a bit more
when they try to equivocate.
The left are the Democratic Party,
the Republican Party, like the is scene
when you have Jimmy Carter saying that
the reason why people does not have health
care is because of Alysse, like do stuff
makes us the left, in my opinion. My
opinion. Right. Not as productive as we
want it to be. See, that's interesting.
I think that, you know, I don't know.
The Jimmy Dawg stuff, I think Jimmy's
operating in a different sort of universe,
I'm more familiar with Kiles views. There's
a difference between useful idealism
to kind of set the goal in a reasonable way
versus counterproductive cynicism. So in my
this is a very limited experience because I
really don't watch other shows like mine. I've
seen a few Jimmy Dorje clips over the last two or
three months when we talked about his his attacks
on me or whatever Jimmy Door right now I would
characterize as counterproductively cynical and
full stop with Kyle. I need to see the examples
you're talking about. But in my experience,
one of the differences between Kyle and me is
that he certainly is more idealistic and I'm
more pragmatic. But I think there's a real value
to idealism because if you have only pragmatist's,
you get into a vortex of only
focusing on incrementalism.
And I think that having the idealism as
part of it, as long as it doesn't get
you beyond being willing to accept steps in the
right direction, I think idealism is valuable.
Yeah, I do I do agree with idealism, yeah,
it's value, but you have to be idealist and
pragmatic at the same time. I completely agree.
And what I'm hearing you say, you're saying
you're saying Kyle, you. Yeah. You're saying
Kyle is idealistic, but not pragmatic enough.
Yes, because I am sure that you are probably
an idealistic person to be certain whether
you will see that in order for you to get
a certain in a political end, you have to
be a bit more pragmatic, because, as I said,
there's nothing wrong with being idealist.
Yeah, it's how do we get that
idealism? We have to be pragmatic, so.
All right. Well, I think, Ricky, I think your
critique is well understood and you've made it
respectfully and I appreciate it.
OK, thank you very much.
All right, Ricky from Jamaica, by the way,
how are things OK in Jamaica right now?
Yeah, we're very we're doing
pretty good here. Good.
All right. All right. Ricky from
Jamaica, hope to hear from you again.
Let's go to a quick break. Sorry I
wasn't able to hear from everybody,
but we will take calls again, and
I hope to hear from you next time.